You your,
you wrote your amcap cause you want to
go to medical school,
right?
And so now the envelope comes and you're
shaking away and the open and it's like
you got 25th percentile just like a
quarter of the people who take the test.
Well what,
what does that mean?
Well this is Sir all blown to hell.
That's for sure.
And so God only knows how many of these
things are going to go to.
Maybe your study habits really need to
be,
you know,
you have to reconstitute yourself all
the way down to the level of your
habits.
It's,
it can be devastating news.
Now,
one of the ways to protect yourself
against something like that,
it's like don't have one plan,
right?
If you're going to stake yourself on
something,
you should throw a couple of alternative
scaffolds up beside you so that you have
somewhere to go.
You want to be a doctor?
Okay,
well you could be a nurse.
It's like it's not a doctor,
but it needs cutting your throat.
You're still doing 80% of what you
wanted to do.
So you want to and you want to think
about this during your whole life,
man,
if you're going to take a high risk,
you want to scaffold yourself and other
areas so that if it fails,
you don't bother them,
doesn't drop out and you die.
And it's also very much worth thinking
about with regards to setting up your
life in general.
It's like
if you concentrate solely on your
career,
you can get along way in your career and
I would say that that's a strategy that
a minority of men preferentially do that
that's all they do.
They worked like 70 80 hours a week.
They go flat out on their career.
They're staking everything on the small
probability of exceptional status in a
narrow domain.
But it's,
it's hard on them.
They don't have a life.
It's very difficult for them to have a
family.
They don't know how to take any leisure
activity like they get very one
dimension.
Now it may be that that unit
dimentionality is the price you have to
pay to be exceptional at one thing,
right?
Because if you're going to be something
like a genius level mathematician and
you want to do that for,
or a scientist say,
it's like you're in your lab,
you're in your lab all the time,
you're working 70 hours a week or 80
hours a week,
you're smart,
you're dedicated,
you're unit dimensional.
And that's how you get to beat all the
other people who are doing that.
It's the only way.
But the problem is you don't get a life.
Now,
if you love being a scientist and you
have that kind of focus of mind,
well first of all,
you're a rare person and second you're
going to pay for it,
but fine.
More power to you.
But,
but it's,
uh,
it's a risky business to do that.
You sacrifice a lot for it.
You know?
And I would say most often if you're
speaking about having a healthy life,
that isn't what you do.
You spread yourself out more.
So,
you know,
you have a family,
you have some things that you do outside
of work that are meaningful to you and
useful.
You,
you have a network of friends.
Um,
that,
that those three things,
a loner for things,
a loner,
plenty to keep you well oriented.
And then if one of those things
collapses,
you know,
everything doesn't go now.
The,
the price you pay for that is,
the more you strive to optimize that
balance,
the less likely you are to be
fantastically successful at any single
one of them.
But you might have a very,
you know,
if you can consider your life as a
whole,
that might be a winning strategy.
One of the things,
Carl Young sad,
I really liked this.
He thought that men went after
perfection and when women went after
wholeness,
so there are different,
they're different value.
Their did their different.
There's something different at the top
of the value hierarchy.
So perfection would be steak it all on
one thing and look for radical success.
Not all,
not that all men do that cause they
don't.
But we're,
we're talking about extremes and at
least with regards to the men that do
that,
the wholeness ideas more like,
well,
I want,
it's like I want one thing in my life to
be 150%
or I want five things in my life to be
80%
well there,
there's a lot more richness in a life
where you have five things operating at
80% but you're not operating in any of
at any of them at 150% so,
and I really believe this because I've
watched men and women go through their
careers now for a long period of time.
And one of the things that,
there's lots of things that produce
this,
but one of the things that I've noticed
is that mostly women in their thirties
bear bail out of unit dimensional
careers.
They won't do them.
They won't,
they won't put in the 80 hours a week
that they would have to put in in order
to dominate that particular area.
And it isn't.
The reason that they won't do it is
because they decide it's not worth it.
And no wonder because why would that be
worth it?
You have to ask yourself though.
It's like,
well you want to be an outstanding
scientist.
It's like okay,
really,
really that's what you want because that
means that's what you do.
Yeah.
Cause you're competing with other
people.
You know they're smart,
they're hardworking.
And if you want to be at the top,
you have to be smarter and work harder
than any of them.
And working hard means working long
hours.
I mean it also means working diligently.
But in the final analysis it's all also
an additive issue.
If I'm smart and hardworking and I can
crank out for 70 hours a week and you do
it for 30 it's like until years,
I'm so far ahead of you,
you will never ever catch up.
So anyways,
and I think partly may be part of the
reason too that women are oriented that
way more than men.
I think there's two reasons.
One is socioeconomic status does not
make women more attractive on the mating
market,
but it does make men more attractive.
And the second is women's timeframe is
compressed,
right?
Cause guys can always say,
well I'll have kids later and they can
say that until they're like 80 whereas
women,
it's like,
no way man,
you gotta get you gotta get it together
by the time were let's say 40 but really
probably by 35 but definitely by 40
cause otherwise it ain't happening and
that's bloody dreadful.
Like the most unhappy people you ever
see.
Hmm.
No,
no.
One of the common roots to extreme
unhappiness is to want children and not
have the,
I wouldn't recommend that.
You know,
you see couples who were in their
thirties one couple in three over the
age of 30 has fertility problems.
That's defined as an inability to
conceive after one year of trying one in
three,
it's worth thinking about because people
are very,
very unhappy if they want to have kids
and then they can't,
man,
you're in the medical mill for 10 years,
if that's,
if that's what happens to you.
So,
okay.
So anyways,
back to this.
Okay.
I think what I'll do,
what time it is,
it is it,
because I'd have to open up a whole new
can of worms so to speak,
to do the next part.
So I think actually what I'm going to do
is just recap what we did and then stop.
Or maybe we can have some questions or
maybe we can call it an early day.
Okay,
so what,
what is the fundamental issue here?
What did we discuss today?
All right,
so you're in a frame and we've laid out
its characteristics.
It has a goal in it,
it has a current position and it has
rules for operating within it.
It governs your perceptions,
which is really critical thing to
understand and well governing your
perceptions.
It's,
it tells you what's useful to you and
what gets in your way.
But most importantly,
it tells you what,
you don't have to pay attention to it.
So as long as your damn frame is
functional,
you can ignore most of the world.
And that means your stress level is way
lower than it would normally be.
Okay.
So perception,
motivation,
all of that's integrated into those
frames.
And then the emotional element comes out
in that with it.
When you're within a frame,
things that move you forward and
validate the framer positive and things
that get in your way and invalidate the
frame are negative and then the next
issue is,
well,
if your frame is invalidated,
exactly what does that mean?
And you can't answer that without
thinking about the hierarchy of frames
because if you're lucky,
it just means your frame needs a minor
alteration that would be equivalent to
Piaget did in assimilation in some
sense.
Right?
You can stay in the frame.
You just make a small adjustment.
I think the Piaget idiom distinction
between assimilation and accommodation
is technically inaccurate because it's a
continuum,
right?
I mean if I,
if I want to grab your pen,
I have a little frame that will enable
me to do that.
You say,
well I'm staying within the frame to
move that out of the way,
but actually I'm not.
What I'm doing is doing a very,
I'm doing a small micro revolution in
the frame,
moving that to pick that up.
And so it's,
I think accommodation,
there's no hard distinction between
assimilation and accommodation.
It's a continuum.
So you'd say,
well,
if,
if the top end of your map gets blown
out,
that requires accommodation.
And if it's just a little micro change
at the bottom,
that's assimilation.
But there's no,
there's no real difference between this
except for scale.
And there's kind of a continual scale,
not an absolute dichotomy.
So,
okay.
So anyways,
back to the back.
The emotion.
Okay,
something happens and it isn't what you
wanted.
What does that mean?
Well,
it could mean anything.
What you do is you start trying to micro
adjust the frame at the highest level of
resolution,
but then you might find that you can't
do that.
So you have to jump up to the next one.
You have to jump up to the next one,
you have to jump up to the next one.
And each time you do that,
the psychophysiological cost increases.
So,
okay.
so we talked about the cost end of the
spectrum and then we also talked about
the engagement end of the spectrum.
And so the idea would be,
well,
if you're,
if you're very much engaged,
say in
cool,
do that again.
If you find it very engaging to play
with your baby,
then you might be doing it in a way
that's an indicating that you're taking
good care of your family,
that you're being a good parent and that
you're being a good person all
simultaneously.
And there's rich meaning in that and
you're the systems that orient you with
regards to meaning are saying,
look,
you're doing this microaction in a way
that benefits the maintenance and maybe
even the expansion of all the frames
that exist above it.
And that's,
that's,
that's exactly what you want.
You want to be doing that all the time
if you can.
And so that implies that you want to
delineate out a pretty well developed
value system so that you're not acting
at odds with yourself.
And you also want to have that
integrated within the broader society so
that society isn't existing towards you
as a continual obstacle and making your
life miserable.